-We should talk about
coronavirus, if you don't mind.
I just don't know as a --
You know, I watch the news.
I read the news.
And I just don't know
who to really trust.
I'm hearing --
-That is the problem
that we have today.
We have a president
who is anti-science,
doesn't believe in the reality
of climate change,
who has appointed Mike Pence,
who is also not known
to be much of a scientist...
[ Laughter ]
...to lead the task force.
And, clearly, at this moment,
you need somebody you can trust
who is going to bring together
the best scientists, doctors,
researchers,
work with the entire world
to do everything that we can
to halt this terrible pandemic.
And I think, clearly,
there are some things
we have to do right away.
The idea that we have so many
of our people in this country --
the only country on Earth,
major country,
that doesn't guarantee
healthcare to all people --
we have to make sure
that everybody right now
feels free when you're sick
to go to a doctor
regardless of your income.
And you know what? The
government will pay that bill.
Number two, we are
the only major country on Earth
not to guarantee
paid medical leave.
So, if you can believe it, there
are people who are sick today
who may actually believe they
have symptoms of the coronavirus
who are going to work
because they have no income.
They're making
12, 13 bucks an hour.
They got to feed their families.
They go to work.
We have got to do what every
other country on Earth does
and guarantee
paid family and medical leave
and do it right now
on an emergency basis.
There was a discussion
recently --
There's a lot of work
being done globally
in terms of a vaccine.
And the Trump administration
was saying,
"Well, we can't guarantee
that it will be affordable.
Got to worry about
the drug companies."
Well, that is a crock.
That is ridiculous.
We have got to make sure that
when that vaccine comes out,
it is available to everybody
in this country
regardless of their income.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mike Pence
being in charge of this
is very interesting
to a lot of people
because they think
that he's going to be --
take the fall from this,
take the hit,
because this is a disaster,
I think.
And then they're going to say
that Trump is going to have
Nikki Haley on the ticket
in 2020.
What are you hearing
over in your...?
-Well, you know, it's ultimately
the President of the
United States' responsibility.
And why you would appoint
a Vice President to lead this
whose own particular record
with regard to science,
with regard to the HIV virus,
has been pretty pathetic.
What you need to do
to give confidence
to the American people is bring
the best minds in the country,
in the world together.
As a leader,
that's what you can be doing.
And don't make this
into politics.
Don't start attacking Democrats.
That is not only absurd,
it is demoralizing
for the American people.
-Last time we talked,
your face lit up
when I mentioned your grandkids.
-Yeah.
-How many grandkids do you have?
-I have seven
very beautiful grandchildren.
-How old -- Uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
How old is the oldest grandkid?
Like, 60? 63?
[ Laughter ]
-Close.
-Thank you very much.
-She's 16, I think.
-Oh, 16.
So she knows
what's going on in the world
and knows the issues
and what the president does.
-Yeah.
-And she probably has opinions.
She can't vote,
but she has opinions.
-Yeah, we drag them out
to a whole lot of rallies.
-Yeah. What do they want?
What's their concern?
And what is the future
for our grandkids?
-I think, you know --
And one of the reasons
that I'm running for President
is for my grandchildren
and for kids all over this
country and all over the world.
And, you know,
as the richest country
in the history of the world,
Jimmy,
you don't hear this much
on television,
but there should not be
a half a million people
sleeping out on the streets
of America tonight.
Half of our people should not
live paycheck to paycheck.
87 million should not lack
the health care that they need.
All of our kids
deserve quality education
regardless of the ZIP code
that you live in.
We should lead the world
in combating climate change.
We got to end the racist and
broken criminal justice system
and a completely discombobulated
immigration system
where people
are terrorized today,
they're going to be
picked up by ICE.
There is so much to be done
in this country,
and we're the richest country
in the history of the world,
but we got to deal with
this greed that's out there.
It's not acceptable
that three people
own more wealth
than the bottom half of America.
It's not acceptable
that the top 1% owns more wealth
than the bottom 92%.
Look, no one has a problem
with people being rich,
but we have got to address
not only this incredible
and unfair distribution
of income and wealth.
It's also power.
It is billionaires
exerting unbelievable
political influence.
They buy and sell politicians.
They make huge
campaign contributions.
If we honestly believe
that we are a democracy,
we got to end billionaire rule
in this country
and create an economy
and a government
that works for all of us.
That's what we got to do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Senator Bernie Sanders.
Senator Bernie Sanders, thank
you so much for being here.